[Music]
ready for tonight
i'm as ready as a person can be after
the fight we're all coming back here for
the champs of victory paulie
don't be late mr malcolm x good news the
chariot is coming you know what look
great
that's right jim brown takes the ball
your record is gonna stand the test of
time
how's everybody feeling tonight all
together yeah
new heavyweight champion of the world
say champ you don't suppose you could
sign an autograph yeah of course man
give him an autograph jim actually mr
cook
oh sure thing brother
don't you think it's about time to party
tonight there's a chance for us to
reflect
hey you mean no one else is coming
well this is all to a hopping star
you all are a bright and shining future
you need to understand what is at stake
here
everything's not so black and white like
you make it out to be but we are
fighting for our lives
you know i know what's going on out
there right
listen listen
brothers and sisters listen listen
listen miami the child i swear we'll
never find a way
where we're going
[Music]
but we're safe to be ourselves
to think like we won't speak without
having to answer to anybody
we have to be there for each other
brothers could move mountains without
lifting a finger
[Music]
you